country is celebrating its seventh
anniversary at Harrah's Las Vegas and
here to tell us how they are celebrating
lucky number seven we have show creators
producers directors they do it all
Angela and Matt stafiel thank you so
much for being here thank you
congratulations seven years for people
who haven't seen the show tell them a
little bit about X country
well the
time
the one thing you don't have to like
country music believe it or not to like
the show to absolutely love the show the
girls are gorgeous as you can see and
the and the choreographies is amazing
the dancing
um it's just a really fun show we have a
comedian John Bazaar and uh it's just
guaranteed a good time yeah I've been in
the theater before and I think it's so
cool how intimate it is you're up close
you can see everything there's not a bad
seat in the house but you guys are going
big this year for seven years what do
you have planned are you adding some new
stuff to the show
yeah so four new numbers are exciting
the opening is really amazing I'm
excited for everyone to see new costumes
and in addition to X country you guys
are this power couple you also have a
successful show going on what'd you say
20 years now 20 years yep X for Less we
just celebrated in March I think it was
yes and then we also have the Magic
Dragon that's celebrating seven years as
well a lot of exciting anniversaries and
people keep coming because it's fun and
like you said you don't have to love
country music but I love country music
and I think it's fun because people get
up on their feet or singing you're
dancing along and so you know when you
come into the show what can what can you
expect on stage is it a little bit of
everything is it you know what kind of
Acts are there I know it's more than
just dancing right we have tradition
traditional country and then also uh you
know new country as well and there is
everything from shower a shower scene to
uh let's see what else um all over a
horse
and a spinning chair that two girls
perform on and that's a new one this
year yep Gotta Love Shania Twain
incorporating our other Vegas Headliners
and you know you got to come see it if
you want to see all the props and
everything you guys congratulations
seven years 20 with extra legs you guys
obviously know what you do and it's a
lot of fun and be sure to come check out
the show they're doing some big things
you got to see all their new stuff X
country performs Thursday through Monday
inside the Harris Cabaret tickets are
available at harrisonlasvegas.com JC
over to you thank you